>> Tucker: THERE IS AN AWFUL
LOT OF EVIDENCE THAT
CONGRESSWOMAN ILHAN OMAR MARRIED
HER OWN BROTHER ILLEGALLY AS A
KIND OF IMMIGRATION FRAUD.
THAT'S NOT THE ONLY TRAUMA IN
HER PERSONAL LIFE.
NOW OMAR HAS FILED FOR DIVORCE
FROM HER NEXT HAS BEEN, THAT
COMES AFTER ALLEGATIONS OF AN
AFFAIR WITH A POLITICAL
CORRESPONDENT.
TRACE GALLAGHER HAS MORE ON THE
STORY.
HEY, TRACE.
>> SHE FILED FOR DIVORCE ON
FRIDAY, 37TH BIRTHDAY EMMA AND
OUR
TO SPLIT THE MARITAL ASSETS.
PRETTY BASIC STUFF.
COURT PAPERS SAY REP IS A NATIVE
OMAR SAID THE MARRIAGE HAD AN
IRRETRIEVABLE BREAKDOWN, UNCLEAR
IF THAT BREAKDOWN INVOLVED
ADC CONSULTANT NAME TO MY NECK
WHO SHE WAS ALLEGEDLY HAVING AN
AFFAIR, THE 90 AFFAIR
CURIOUS CONSIDERING HIS
ESTRANGED WIFE SAID
BY PUBLICLY INTRODUCING THE BOY
TO OMAR WHO, "AT THAT TIME
GARNERED A PLETHORA OF MEDIA
ATTENTION ALONG WITH DEATH
THREATS, ONE RISING TO THE LEVEL
OF ARRESTING THE KNOWN WOULD BE
ASSASSIN THAT SAME WEEK."
SAYS THE AFFAIR BEGAN WHILE HER
HUSBAND WAS WORKING FOR ILHAN
OMAR'S CAMPAIGN AND NOW
CONSERVATIVE WATCHDOG GROUPS
HAVE FILED COMPLAINTS WITH THE
FEDERAL ELECTION COMMISSION
BECAUSE OMAR'S CAMPAIGN
REPORTEDLY PAID TEN
HIM FOR FUND-RAISING, CROWD
EXPENSES.
QUESTION IF THOSE FUNDS WERE
USED TO PURSUE THE AFFAIR.
ILHAN OMAR MARRIED BACK IN 2002,
THEY SEPARATED 2008 AND LEGALLY